I'm an engineer by training and so
engineering discipline tells us to start
with first principles and so the easiest
thing to do is to start by defining what
is value and what is a proposition right
so if you turn to to merriam-webster
right you know this is the the answer
that you get I think it's a relatively
simple explanation right that a value
proposition at the end of the day really
is some sort of offer it's a fair
exchange for some good right and so now
the question becomes how do you describe
that good in a way that is appealing and
enticing for a prospective customer and
I'm going to build this hypothesis
throughout the the talk today that the
moral equivalent of the who what where
when why and how are these five elements
right so it's the articulation of the
primary purpose of the product or
service it's identifying the target
audience it's capturing the significance
to a prospective customer its
identifying and specifying the category
in which you compete and it explains the
the uniqueness of the product or the
service now the reality is all five of
those statements sound quite obvious
unfortunately it's deceptively simple
right and so anyone who has gone through
the exercise of actually trying to write
out your value proposition has probably
found that it's much easier to list
these five properties that should apply
than it is to actually figure out how to
translate them into a real-life
circumstance so what I wanted to do is I
thought maybe I would just kind of
double click on these five and spend a
little bit of time talking about what
are the the questions that you want to
answer in thinking about each of those
five elements so if we start with
purpose um this one is probably the the
easiest one to describe and for some
reason entrepreneurs get it wrong most
and at the core of it it's really the
cry answering the question what does the
product or service do right and the the
place where I think entrepreneurs often
go awry here is they spend lots of time
particularly in the technology arena
where most of them are engineers by
training and I can say that as one end
up describing the product right so they
say well I've got this widget right and
here are all the neat properties of the
widget right and what they forget to do
is then translate why those properties
actually matter to anybody right it's
sort of a well I've laid out the
property
and you know therefore you should be
able to draw all the logical inferences
of why you care right but if you think
about it think about the last time you
read an ad right my bet is you read five
or six words of the ad and then you
quickly turn the page in the magazine
write it you had to capture your
attention very very quickly and so when
you talk about what does the purpose of
the product you need to give a very
succinct summary and statement that
really captures the imagination of the
audience that you're addressing so the
second part to it is to identify the
target audience right and this is sort
of the question of who cares right who's
going to go buy this product or service
you can certainly chart to think about
some of the quantifiable elements of
this right the @am analysis some sort or
or understanding kind of how many
dollars are spent in that particular
category or on that particular problem
so there are ways to put some parameters
around that audience but I will submit
that you want to be able to define who
is the audience you really care about
servicing right that's going to have
implications throughout the rest of the
value proposition statement and then I'm
going to argue that the value
proposition effectively becomes the
roadmap for building out the overall
business plan right and so understanding
who the customer is determines a whole
lot of other elements to your business
strategy yeah
[Music]
ya know I think it's a it's an important
distinction and it's probably
particularly pronounced when you talk in
terms of enterprise software when you
think about selling to an end consumer
the ultimate decision-maker is probably
the same individual that you are
messaging to but in the enterprise
context that's actually often very
different and in fact it's complicated
by the fact that the person that you
initially message to is probably not the
person who ultimately has budget
Authority and so thinking about an
understanding who each of the
stakeholders are will play a role in how
you craft the the ultimate value
proposition and sort of the most
effective value proposition statements
I've seen when you're talking about a
b2b sort of business ends up crafting
the value proposition in such a way that
some of the elements speak specifically
to the initial hook into the
organization and others speak to the
person who's actually going to pay for
it right and so being able to understand
each of those stakeholders ends up being
a pretty important distinction so as you
get to the next level down okay so the
third element then I think is
significance so what are the key
benefits this is the the enumeration
right so when somebody said write the
value proposition this is probably what
you immediately thought of right it's
the the list of the 25 things that this
thing is going to do for you and
implicit in this is a is a ranking right
the reality is that you probably can
come up with 25 great things that your
new startup is going to go do but only
two or three of those are really really
important and so some of this exercise
is making that list and then starting to
figure out which ones are right in the
priority order right and to the point of
the earlier question sort of which ones
do you then want to ultimately select to
talk about whether you're talking in
terms of your marketing message or your
sales process or things like that what's
useful
size is described life before your
surgeon arrived and then life after your
salute your life particular audience to
talk exactly so that's the the second
bullet here is exactly that um one of
the exercises that I often do remember I
said that I get a lot of entrepreneurs
who who are engineers and so they tell
me what the product is and the easiest
way to tease out the the answer for them
of what is the value proposition ends up
being exactly what you described right
it's walk me through the day and the
life before
walk me through in a day and the life
after and then understand kind of what
those those deltas were the third sort
of part to significance I think really
kind of speaks to this question around
why does somebody care but it really is
the magnitude of the caring right and
then the sort of analogy that people
draw is this this question of is it a
painkiller or is it a vitamin right so a
vitamin is something you know you should
take but you probably forgot every
morning and a painkiller is something
you absolutely need by five o'clock
right so you want to make sure that
whatever the product or services that
you're delivering if you're a startup
I'll submit it has to be in that second
category it has to be a painkiller right
there's just too much noise to kind of
capture the imagination and attention of
a customer if you don't have something
that is so compelling they absolutely
need to buy it and I think that plays a
role in understanding which of these
kind of list of value propositions are
the ones you pick to focus on right
because it's the ones that are so
significant that it jumps off the page
that in fact the customer probably knew
they have the problem and actively went
searching for the answer as opposed to
you're having to evangelize why your
product or service even mattered to them
to begin with the last piece to it which
is the by far the hardest to do it at
kind of the very beginning but I think
is something that you can add to the
story over time is the quantification of
all of this right and in the you know
the enterprise context that I spend most
of my time that's oftentimes termed
around some sort of ROI analysis of how
many dollars can be saved ultimately or
how many dollars can be generated but in
but it's some sort of quantitative
metric right that allows you to validate
that the significance actually is
significant right
put some anchors around it this is
something that's really hard to do on
day one so if you've got a neat idea for
a company you want to go start you
probably don't have an idea of how to
quantify all the benefits yet but it's
something that you can layer into the
story as you start to build out
real-life customers the fourth one is
category and here that this sort of
speaks to a belief that I have about how
people think about the world I think a
lot of people use categories as a simple
heuristic to think about buckets of
things right it gives you sort of a
mental framework to say well that's sort
of in this bucket right and I can think
about this whole bucket in a particular
way when you think about how to build a
startup now and certainly that's true in
the technology arena but I think it can
be generalized as well you need to think
about what category do you want to be a
part of right and the two options here
really are some existing category right
hopefully one that has favorable
attributes to it right there are lots of
categories that have unfavorable
attributes and you probably don't want
to associate yourself with those but the
other option is to create an entirely
new category I think there's this
natural temptation to say well mine is
totally unique I have something that it
no one has ever thought of before and
it's so different on in my own category
and I'll argue that that's actually the
hardest route to take because now you
have to convince people not only of your
company in your product but you've now
got to convince them this is a category
as well and so you need to think through
kind of what those trade-offs are but
it's an important part to this value
proposition because it anchors the
discussion around some reference point
that people already understand whether
that's sort of the intersection of two
things that's now this new category or
it's something that is already existing
that people know about and then the last
element to the value proposition is the
uniqueness right this is sort of the
differentiation of what makes you
different and there are a few dimensions
to this that I think that are important
obviously you want to kind of
differentiate yourself relative to the
status quo right so what are the
substitutes that are available today
that people are already perhaps using to
solve this problem back to kind of the
day in
life example you know but you need to
somehow sort of cheese out kind of what
what is unique and different about this
but I'll argue that what's important
here is as much the the axes that you
pick as the actual elements of
differentiation and the reason is is
this sets up sort of the long term
vision of the company so over time right
the goal is to build a sustainable
company right it's not to sort of
differentiate your product initially and
so if you're going to build a company
that's sustainable you need to think
about what are the sustainable
attributes over time right so in the
world that I live in you know lots of
people tell me well it's really hard
technology to build right and the
reality is is it you know that may be
true but Microsoft can throw a thousand
engineers at this problem right or
Google can put two thousand engineers on
the problem you know is it really so
fundamentally different that that's
that's really the secret sauce here was
it you just worked at it for a while um
so the same can be applied to a lot of
different contexts to think about what
are the long-term basis of competition
in any given product market all right so
where do you go with this right so once
you've kind of answered these sets of
questions around these five dimensions
right other than sort of an interesting
academic exercise what do we what do we
now do with it right and I think the the
first application of it ends up being
around the elevator pitch you hear the
elevator pitch discussion and vocabulary
come up primarily in the context of
investors but the exact same thing
applies when you're talking to a
customer right so if I grab you on the
walk from here to my car and I want to
sell you something I need to be able to
explain pretty succinctly what it is
that I'm offering you right back to
value and proposition I got to be able
to describe that for you in relatively
short order and so you know I will use
this mad libs exercise as sort of a way
to to kind of force it into a sentence
obviously it doesn't have to be a single
sentence but I think it gives you a
reasonable construct for how you might
go about writing an elevator pitch right
ABC corporation provides category
solutions to target customer for purpose
which allows them to benefit by
leveraging unique technology right and
that ends up being a really short
sentence
it's probably really hard to do because
my bet is that you've got an answer that
is two or three paragraphs long for
every single blank right and the trick
now is how do you get that down to two
or three words to describe it right once
you've done that and iterated on it a
few times you now have your elevator
pitch everything that follows right so
floors one through five end up being
this first sentence right six to the top
ends up being all the supporting detail
and force yourself to put all the rest
of the information the validation of
customers the partners you've talked to
the additional reasons perhaps the ROI
you know all of those other elements now
become secondary and subordinate to this
first sentence right this is the most
important sentence so if the person
you're talking to only remembers one
thing about you hopefully they'll
remember this one sentence all right so
once you've crafted the value prop right
mostly because I'm on the venture side I
get the question all the time of well
how do I convince an investor that they
should invest in this right and I'm
going to answer the question in the
context of a VC in particular but I
don't think VCS are all that different
than any other investor that you might
try to address so the first part of it
is that the value proposition exercise
that you've just gone through actually
forms the cornerstone for the entire
investor value proposition as well right
it's the way it's the teaser that got
you the initial meeting right it's the
it's the fundamental aspect of the
executive summary that you sent it's the
story arc for the investor presentation
overall right and it ends up becoming
the cornerstone of the investment thesis
so when I sit in a partner meeting and I
try to convince my partners that I want
to go invest in some company and I need
to get their buy-in to make that happen
I'm going to rely on that value
proposition is the reason to do it right
and I think the same thing can be
generalized to any investor having said
that though that same moral equivalent
of the who what where when why and how
can be applied in the investor context
as well right you just change sort of
the descriptors around each of those
five elements so is the purpose worthy
of assuming startup risk right remember
that in the venture business call it
seven out of ten investments fail right
so it means that the three that succeed
had better be really good to make up for
the more towel
on all of the others right so is the
purpose worthy the second is is the
target audience large enough right so or
have you narrowly defined the audience
that you're addressing to be so small
that I don't plausibly believe that you
can build a big company here so make
sure that it's a large enough audience
the third one is is the significance
valuable enough to customers this goes
back really to my painkiller discussion
right is it a painkiller the fourth is
in an attractive category for investment
so the discussion we just had there are
certainly some unfavorable categories
that if I said it is in category X every
one of my partners would shake their
head and go no no no move on right so
you need to understand that and then the
fifth one is what is particularly unique
about this startup right and as
difficult as it is to hear I can assure
you that for every business plan that
I've seen and funded I've seen ten or
fifteen others that were attacking the
exact same problem right and as much as
we'd all like to think that we're truly
unique and have unique insights that no
one else in the world has come up with
the reality is that's not true
and so what is it that is unique and
special about this one project that is
an investor commands your attention okay
so let me just ground this in a in a
real discussion of a real company which
I think might make a make some of it
come a little bit more alive so I picked
a company called the kimby systems it's
probably as unsexy to anybody outside
the tech space as they come but it had a
fantastic outcome so that's why I like
to speak about it um this particular
company at a high level is in the test
and development automation space so if
you've ever written software before you
know that one of the processes that you
go through is you do this quality
analysis to figure out whether the
product is functional or not on this
particular product completely automates
that entire process for you so there's a
you can imagine all of the benefits that
come from that around reduced labor
improved product quality etc etc um so
the way these guys came up with this
idea is this guy Wilson at the time was
running he was VP of engineering for an
organization and he had built a series
of tools that helped him run his
engineering organization and automate
some of the testing that he was doing
and one of his friends came up and asked
for a copy of it and so he gave it to
him second friend came up
and asked for coffee and they gave it to
him and about the third time that he was
asked for copy of his software the light
bulb went off and he said ways that
maybe there's actually an interesting
business to be had here and so he gave
it some thought and he went and found
his partner James Phillips who
co-founded the company with him and
together they decided that they wanted
to go start this company and so they
started the company in 2004 I met them
in late 2004 early 2005 I was introduced
by a mutual friend and they decided that
they wanted to go out and raise a series
a financing now just to give you the
spoiler I did not end up investing in
the series a because of category it's in
the test and development automation
space which is about as I said it as
unsexy as they come and so I wasn't sure
that the financial returns were actually
sufficient enough to make it worth
proceeding and so I passed on the series
a I ended up investing in the series B
mostly because they had built enough of
a product that they convinced me that
there was some magic there that they
could really go after the ultimate
vision the interesting kind of footnote
to it is we sold the company five and a
half months after my series B investment
to VMware and it now forms the basis of
all of their automation suite so great
outcome but I use it as an example
because it probably is the best investor
pitch I have ever seen this is the value
proposition and if you read through it
for just a second you'll see how they
applied the madlibs exercise effectively
right to each of the core elements and
my bet is that even though you don't
know a bunch of the jargon or may not
know all of the jargon my bet is that
you've got a reasonably good idea of at
least why this is sort of an interesting
business all right and you could at
least map to does this apply to me or
not so that's the elevator pitch that
got my attention initially and this was
the second slide in the slide deck it
was the value proposition and so he was
trying to articulate to me why it was a
customer cared about this and I'll let
you kind of in the backdrop read through
sure to each of these bullet points and
I think the thing that will hopefully
stand out in your mind as you read
through them is every one of this speaks
to a business reason for somebody
wanting to buy this product right now
it's missing the quantification around
this it was a series a company and so he
didn't actually have any real customers
of
than the ones that he'd given it to so
you know he didn't really know sort of
how much it improved each of these
elements but there was a good basis to
believe that it did so this was slide
number two and I think slide 17 was this
one this was his last slide in the slide
deck investment highlights and if you
walk through it you'll notice that it
actually addresses basically all five of
my who what where when why questions
right and sets it in a context of why
does an investor care if we take that as
sort of the backdrop what I thought I
would do is kind of step back a little
bit and just talk more generally about
what to do venture folks look at and
what are some of the properties of
successful companies I think that colors
how you think about the value
proposition statement particularly to
investors but but more generally as well
so the first part of it I call my
motherhood and apple pie spiel right
which is what a VCS look for it is
pretty simple right it comes down to
people market and product I think you
will find wild debates between the first
two on the list in their sequence but to
discussion we just had the third one is
by far the third one and as much as that
pains me I'm an engineer I love my
discipline but we're we are now
necessary but but far far from
sufficient to build a real company and
so the focus for venture guys ends up
hinging primarily on the first two
people in market and you'll find a lot
of debate over the the actual order
between those I personally put market
first because I think you can find great
teams who will figure it out over time
as long as you're in a market that gives
you enough degrees of freedom but there
are an equal number of VCS who believe
very strongly that you find great
entrepreneurs and they'll change the
market if they need to in order to get
to a successful outcome but the three
sort of you know at a high level it's
exceptional entrepreneurs large rapidly
growing market an innovative and
differentiated product this part of it
you know clearly applies to venture back
tech companies but you know remember we
think about a very small sliver of the
universe right the vast majority of
entrepreneurial activity in this country
has absolutely no basis for venture
investing and so you know the things
that we look for right are probably some
what you need
but but I would argue that you know to
some varying degree all three of these
elements end up being pretty key for any
entrepreneurial activity the fourth one
which almost invariably gets left out of
the discussion and oddly enough ends up
being the one that company stubbed their
toe on the most is the go-to-market
elements right so it's how do you
connect the dots if you have the first
three and it's perfect but you have no
idea how you're actually going to get it
to a customer somehow and sell it to
them right it doesn't really matter and
so the fourth thing right this go to
market strategy
ends up being the one that everyone
overlooks in the discussion but it's
always the one that causes the company
to fail right with the exception as sort
of you know one of the the first three
just being you know completely out there
so if I spend a little bit of time kind
of looking at each of these three sort
of what are the the qualities that you
know when I'm looking at an investment
signal to me that it's a really
interesting opportunity and for you as
entrepreneurs the things that you want
to get across in your your presentation
right the first part of it starts a team
and the the observation here is the team
is built around a couple of key people
and that that's universally true they're
almost always or one or two people in
the company that ultimately define the
success of the company right in the
context of the tech world it's usually
the rock star engineer or to combine
with the one or two people that really
understand the business better than
anyone else but it's always that core
nucleus and somehow that doesn't change
so you can go to almost any public
company even in the tech landscape and
my bet is that if you ask internally
you'll find three or four people that
are the root of the company right
everyone else is still contributing it's
not that they are useless by any means
but there are a few people that really
determine where that company goes and so
identifying early on in thinking about
funding a company who those people are
is absolutely essential right because
you're looking for those rock stars so
what are some of the properties to those
rock stars it's sort of one of these
things that you know what when you see
it but but let me try to sort of
identify what some of the common
qualities are the first one is that
they're smart and passionate they
generally have very unique insight
they're driven to succeed and here there
has to be a drive that is unwavering the
reality is is that if you actually sat
down and logically analyze the chance of
success no one would be an entrepreneur
right you'd have to be in sync like you
would right I mean the chance of failure
is so incredibly high and so in order to
power through all of that you have to
have an uncompromising drive to build a
company the third one is that there's
got to be a unique insight right and we
spend a bunch of the time kind of
hovering around this point in the
discussion so far right and I think
there's this general belief that well
well you know in the tech world that's
somehow has to do with product and
technology and the reality is is that
often doesn't right it could be around a
deep understanding of customer and I
think the akin be example is actually a
really good example here it was their
insight because they had been the
customer right they built the product
for themselves right they really knew
what the customer needed and that was
what set them apart right that's why no
one else was able to build that product
before the second part right could be
technology could be process right so
perhaps you have a unique process that
might be semiconductor process that
could be a business model process and
then the last one is you might have a
business model innovation right SAS used
to be a business model differentiator
fourth desire to recruit a world-class
management team I have this theory about
people they're a player's B players and
C players a players love to hire other a
players B players love to have somebody
that they're above right so they go out
and hire a lot of C players
the problem is B players can hire C
players way faster than a players can
hire other a players right and so you
end up in this death spiral pretty
quickly you have to have a commitment to
only hire eight players right so the
general rule of thumb is I'd only want
somebody that was better than me right I
need to be the dumbest person in every
room right and if you use that as sort
of the bar you're constantly raising the
average in the company next one is you
need to know what's missing on the team
I think there's this temptation to sort
of put this front up to to investors and
say we've got everything right it's sort
of you know well let me let me take the
list of titles and figure out who is
going to cover each one of those so that
we've got them all covered and the
reality is we don't want that right we
we'd actually much rather there be some
candid discuss
on hey you know we don't have this skill
set we ought to go find that person
right as long as that quart nucleus is
there it doesn't it doesn't really
matter beyond that um the other piece to
it right that I think is related is this
weird problem around titles people seem
to get hung up on titles for for bizarre
reasons I got to tell you I would much
rather see a business plan that had
everyone called a director and then sort
of this discussion around maybe we'll
need better people maybe we won't then
to have everyone as VPS and knowing that
several of them actually aren't right so
think about kind of how those things
influence how investors view you so the
last thing that I'll note on team and
this again is specific to the the
venture context you know the VC is
trying to size you up to figure out
whether you're somebody they want to
work with for the next three to five
years right and the hope is that you are
are doing the same the joke that I
always make right is that it's sort of
like marriage that you're marrying your
VC the the rejoinder to that of course
is you can't actually divorce your VC
once you pick them so market so what's
important about market it's all about
the the size of the market and how fast
it's growing I would argue that the bar
that most venture folks apply is that it
needs to be a billion dollar plus market
that you're going after and the reason
is simply a pattern recognition of how
what percentage of the market are you
likely to be able to get and so venture
folks sort of apply this heuristic of
you might be able to get 10% or so of
the market over time and so it needs to
be a billion dollar plus opportunity to
justify it um second element we've spent
a lot of time already talking about the
the pain and the fact that it needs to
be an acute pain we talked a little bit
about the fact that it could be
quantifiable and some of the ways that
you could go about describing it I think
the the last point was one that we did
not talk about before and that's the the
observation that it actually matters
where the market is going as opposed to
where it is today and so part of the
story needs to be how does this unfold
across the dimension of time right so
you may have a story right now but what
does that look like two years from now
or three years from now or five years
from now so what are some of the
elements here of the the go to market
plan the first part is the the marketing
strategy right so
you get the message to your customers
and obviously this varies pretty widely
by category in which you compete but
there there are a whole lot of sort of
constituent elements here one that I
think you ought to make sure to think
about in this context is partners right
so how do you get partner leverage
somehow in your business model it is
relatively rare that a small start-up
goes at it alone and succeeds without
some giant befriended them along the way
so in my kimby example they were
befriended by both VMware and Microsoft
that was the unfair competitive
advantage that they got very early in in
their life second part is the sales
model and distribution and so consumer
perhaps there's less to be discussed
here if you're talking about enterprise
software there's a whole richness of
options to choose from but these are you
know having them well thought out and
making sure that it's a coherent plan
makes a lot of sense or is necessary and
in the last piece is sort of the pricing
right asura how do you monetize it again
the range of options is large what
venture folks are looking for here is
not that you have the answer but that
you've got several hypotheses of what
the answer might be and a systematic way
to go prove them out right so in the
consumer context you might say I think
there are four different revenue streams
and here's how I'm going to be able to
turn each one of them on and here's sort
of the key metrics to know whether it's
working or not right and that's a
sufficient answer for an early-stage
company the next part on the how do you
deliver it to market is the the
financial operating plan and the test
here is not you actually have all the
answers it's simply a reasonableness
test right does does the story hold
together in a way that it actually makes
sense right or if you busy you know
crafted this whole thing and now when
you put it on paper you realize that
your customer acquisition cost is $500
and you think you can get $100 out of
them right and suddenly the model no
longer works right so it's really a
reasonableness test to see whether you
can put something together that holds
together it's consistent with the rest
of the story the reality is we don't we
neck recognize that no company will
actually successfully hit the model that
that you give to us on day one if you do
that would be awesome
and congratulations you're one of the
first alright
so so product um so the first
observation here we kind of already
talked about and that's that positional
advantages are rarely sufficient I can't
tell you the number of times that I've
seen a pitch that says we have a first
mover advantage and I always challenge
the entrepreneur to cite me an example
in technology where first mover one you
may be able to come up with one I'm yet
to find an entrepreneur that's fast
enough on their feet to come up with one
for me but but you might but it's pretty
rare so rather than relying on that
instead focus on some sort of capability
based and we've already talked through
sort of what some of the the range of
options there might might be technical
differentiation seems to be the one
where people have traditionally having
their hat the most I think that's moving
towards some sort of innovators dilemma
where there is a belief that the
incumbents are unable to reach a
particular market perhaps the business
model shift perhaps it's something else
that that keeps them from following you
clear and succinct value proposition
we've spent a lot of time kind of
already talking about that so the ones
are a caveat that I will apply to it is
its applies specifically to product is
the 1.0 release right so the other
problem that you can run into is I call
it the Cadillac problem of you come in
and you say well here all the things
that's going to do and we should have it
ready for you in eight years right and
you know that's just not acceptable
right what you want to get out there you
want to start getting feedback earlier
to figure out whether or not you're
heading in the right direction it's
entirely possible that you picked all
the right features and in eight years
you'll be spot on but I'd much rather
deliver something in six months and then
iterate and then deliver something else
in another six months and continuing
that refinement process so the test for
for venture guys is what's the minimum
set in the 1.0 release and the test that
I always ask people is to go through the
exercise of pose to yourself what is the
fewest number of features that I need to
provide to get money in exchange right
and and and as long as that's the
smallest unit the smallest quantum of
value you need you can deliver right
that's what should be scoped to the one
not oh release the
they're sort of point here around
leveraging trends and standards you know
it's much easier as a start-up to write
of tidal wave right so find something
that's wildly successful and figure out
how to latched yourself on to it if I go
back to the akin be example they route
the virtualization wave right you had to
be hiding under a rock someplace in it2
not to know why virtualization was
important over the last three years and
they were able to sort of attach
themselves to that and it really didn't
matter sort of whether they did anything
wrong right they still enjoyed all the
benefits of that category and writing
that standard in wave the key to
thinking about your operating plan is
how to schedule removal of risk from the
business and what you want to do is you
want to link that to financing events
right so each individual round of
financing should be predominantly around
removing one key element of risk in the
business right so if you are a consumer
business the first risk I would submit
to you that matters is customer
acquisition can you get anyone to come
to the site right the second one might
be engagement can I once I've got them
there can I get them to do something on
that site and then the third one might
be once I got them there and doing
something can I figure out some way of
extracting money either from them or
some third party because they're there
right um so that would be an example of
a progression of risk reduction and I
think you want to go through that same
exercise irrespective of the the product
category so the classic example of
innovators dilemma would be a condition
where a business model shift is required
and the usual example that people cite
is that there is some giant in the
sector in order to change their business
model actually has to effectively get
rid of the existing business so an
example right that was cited earlier was
sort of this move to SAS so if I have a
legacy business right where I'm out
elephant hunting for multi-million
dollar enterprise deals and I probably
have a 20% annuity stream on maintenance
from my existing customers to suddenly
shift all of that and go sell SAS
software right as a subscription
business so I don't get paid up front
I get paid in this annuity stream
overtime right is going to really
disrupt my existing business because
I've got a sales force that's comped
this way I've got a marketing machine
that set
an engineered to handle it right I can't
change my business overnight and to do
it is going to erode my revenue right
and so if I'm a public company how do I
go to the street and tell them that next
year I'm actually going to do half the
revenue but not to worry it's
subscription so I'll get it back in two
years right you know you try to have
that discussion with an institutional
investor so it's those sorts of things
right that pose and innovators dilemma
and you'll find them in selective
markets you oftentimes in the consumer
context hear it around things that
Google might face right or problems that
Yahoo might face in shifting their
business model right that's would be
another example but you got to think
about kind of where it is that the
incumbent can't follow you because of
some structural reason all right so what
I thought I'd do next is just spend a
little bit of time talking about the
venture kind of financing process a
little bit
so once we've gone through this exercise
of what is the value proposition I've
now sort of built out the business plan
based on that right how do I turn that
into something that I can go talk to
investors about and the first step of
that I think is to write the investor
pitch the investor presentation has
roughly these eight sections to it if
you think about it it should map pretty
well to what you put into a business
plan if anyone actually wrote a business
plan any more right instead everyone
puts it into PowerPoint and it becomes
this document um these are sort of the
eight key elements um it needs to be
roughly 15 to 20 slides and the trick
here is sort of hold yourself to that
right resist the temptation to double
that or triple that I can't tell you the
number of pitches that have come in that
have you know 80 slides and when you
actually go through it 78 of them talk
about the great technology and 2 of them
tell me about all the rest right so
these are the eight make sure that
they're all in there it means that you
get roughly one to two slides per topic
area make sure to use them wisely the
key to this right is that it's all about
the fundamentals right it's the core
element to each of these eight parts of
the story if you manage to entice an
investor they're going to want to know
more
right and that's okay remember that the
investor pitch and I'm going to make
this point over and over again it's a
sales document right with the exception
of consumers right and you're some sort
of you know spontaneous purchase
at point of sale or something you know
it's a long courting process right and
the same thing holds true here you're
not expecting to get a check on the
first meeting right and if you are you
you ought to you know reset expectations
it's going to take a series of
successive meetings and so like any
great sales process you want to tease
the customer a little bit right tell
them all the great things and get them
to ask questions to get to the next
level of detail so it's fine to have
more detail than these eight slides put
them in the appendix right so that when
somebody asks what about this you can
say oh I got that answer over here right
but keep the body of the document to the
core core parts of the business so from
there you know I think there seems to be
this desire to write executive summaries
personally I wouldn't bother I think
it's a compiled waste of time I try to
read them as fast as I possibly can not
because I am NOT actually interested in
the content but I'd much rather get the
investor deck that wants me through it
more methodically all the elements of
the business to the degree that you
choose to write an executive summary
please make sure to limit it to one page
maybe to the executive summaries that
run 15 pages of prose take way longer to
get through and I'm Way more tired by
the time I get to page 15 then if I just
walk through the deck and was able to
focus on the key elements that I care
about understanding um so if you're
going to do the executive summary keep
it short keep it succinct address sort
of each of the the major elements but
bear in mind that again it's a sales
document right so you want to tease
people about what is really exciting and
interesting about this to get them to
want to ask more questions I won't
bother going through this this is an
incredibly dense list but this is sort
of the set of questions that you would
want to ask about each of the elements
of the story and make sure then that
your slide deck addresses them because
these are the questions whether the
investor actually asks them or not these
are the questions that are running
through their mind and they're mentally
kind of checking them off and going okay
well that's not a problem that one's one
I need to understand that's one that you
know they got completely wrong you know
from my perspective right you know
they're going to try to average out and
weigh sort of all of these questions
and in this is sort of my checklist so
if you answer all of these questions
right you're probably about an investor
who's really interested now you're going
to kiss a lot of frogs along that
process because someone's going to
disagree with some elements of the story
but this is the set of things that they
are mentally going through right it's
the questions on the previous slide but
sort of you know enumerated one at a
time so I'll leave it here for just a
second so you can kind of skim through
it certainly so the last thing I just
wanted to talk about on the venture
process was the process itself right so
how do you how do you actually raise
venture financing and so this is kind of
the the rough timeline and I'll just
kind of walk quickly through each of the
steps the the first step is to somehow
contact the venture firm and and here
you want to make sure to get a personal
introduction if you can write the just
to give you sort of a sense of the
numbers as a partnership we look at
about 6,000 investment opportunities a
year I personally look at between 800
and 900 investments a year so now you
start to do the math that means that I'm
looking at roughly three to four
investment opportunities per day right
of those I'm going to take meetings with
about a hundred and twenty companies
right so about one every other day and
of those 120 I'm gonna take second
meetings with 40 and of those second
meetings I will ultimately invest in one
so I had to go from 800 to one
is a very steep winnowing process that
doesn't mean that the other 799 are bad
businesses right it's for whatever
reason it didn't capture my attention in
my interest right along one of these
dimensions because I have to go through
this process of figuring out what one do
I care about and so now if you map that
into this timeline well how do you
maximize your chance of success well at
the first step you just need to get to a
meeting right it's you want to get from
the introduction to a meeting and how do
you maximize your chance of that well
you make sure that it's the strongest
relationship you possibly can get is the
original introduction right so as an
example if a CEO who I backed multiple
times and has been successful for me
writes to me and says here's this
company you have
we need to take a look at it's the
greatest thing since sliced bread right
I'll guarantee you that I'm going to
clear my schedule the next day and we're
going to have time for coffee right to
the other end of the extreme over the
transom haven't had a chance to meet you
before I absolutely will read your
presentation
III make sure that I get through every
single presentation never gets sent to
me but it means that I may not give it
as much attention right and it means
that the bar to get over is just higher
so my recommendation entrepreneur is is
find a personal relationship that gets
you the original introduction and try to
reach the person at the venture firm who
knows that domain right so if you show
up and say Tom I want to talk to you
about a clean tech deal right that's not
my area
I just you know it's an interesting
space I think it's awesome but I have
partners that know the clean tech space
that's not my thing and the same thing
holds true across most firms so you want
to identify the person that is relevant
to the type of business that you are
looking to start second step is the
initial presentation so the way these
work is you come in and you pitch for an
hour we tell you it's an hour the little
secret is we almost always hold 90
minutes on our calendar the 60 minute
pitch needs to walk through those 20
slides you want to expect that half the
time will be spent with questions half
of our questions will be things that
you've actually answered in the slide
deck but you just answered them in a
different order and we asked you when we
thought of them the other half are just
completely ludicrous questions that are
either because we know the domain and we
want to just skip through 15 of the
slides because we already know the
answers on the 15 and we want to get
back to that part that really makes you
different versus the other 10 or I'm
just out to lunch and I have you know I
don't understand your business yet and
so I ask some silly question the result
is you end up needing that full 60
minutes to get through your 20 slides
about half of it will be spent on the
slides about half of it will be sent
answering questions remember though the
key to that first meeting right is not
to get a term sheet right it's simply to
get a second meeting so what happens
from there well they're a series of
successive meetings partnerships venture
firms or structures partnerships which
means everyone in the firm sort of
somehow needs to agree on an investment
different firms have different kind of
balancing acts of how many people need
to agree to make a deal happen but
generally speaking it's some sort of
consensus and so the the process means
that you need to meet with a number of
different partners in the firm to start
building consensus
this is a prospective investment that
you want to pursue so hopefully if
things go well you'll get invited back
to a series of successive meetings that
could be a couple of meetings that could
be five or six meetings generally as
those meetings progress they'll start to
invite some of their experts in right so
I have this network of people that I
know in various domains that I've really
trust and so I'm likely to ask them to
join some of these meetings or I might
ask you to go with them directly or I
might introduce you to some customer
prospects that I know right it's a bunch
of different ways to start triangulating
is this a project right that I'm really
excited about and if you guys use the
process well as entrepreneurs it's
actually to your advantage right because
you've gotten a whole lot of free
networking you've met a whole bunch of
potential people that you can recruit to
your company you might have picked up
some interesting customer prospects you
might have picked up some interesting
partner prospects so the process is
painful don't get me wrong right I
raised financing before getting on this
side of the table it's a painful process
but there's actually a lot of good
learning that happens a long way that
eventually leads to the last stage of
the of the due diligence process or the
kind of front-end process that
culminates in a partner presentation all
right and that's sort of the final
blessing you come in you pitch to the
entire firm everyone in the partnership
regardless of their domain sector
generally is in attendance and they make
a thumbs-up thumbs-down decision
effectively at the end of the meeting if
things go well it's thumbs up you
usually then get a term sheet within a
couple of days the term sheet is sort of
the first pass at the negotiated
structure of the investment you'll have
a few kind of cranks of that until you
kind of agree to what the terms are and
then you enter kind of legal due
diligence right and that part generally
takes anywhere from 30 to 45 days and at
the end of that the money is wired to
you and it's in the bank and we go from
there
so that's the the basic process yeah
yeah so our expectation is that you will
our preference is that you don't
if I remove sort of my venture hat for a
second and I put back on my entrepreneur
hat the guidance that I usually get is
that you want to approach somewhere
around half a dozen venture firms at a
time any more than that and you're going
to be swamped with first meetings and
diligence requests any fewer than that
and you run the risk that they fall out
right and you sort of rinse and repeat
so you do that for the first half a
dozen if none of those germinate you go
to the next half-dozen right and you
sort of just systematically start
working your way through the list do you
consider the I mean at some point just
before you write
yeah certainly at the time that you sign
the the term sheet you would tell the
other prospective investors that you're
not moving forward with them up to that
point the expectation generally is that
you know everyone knows that you're
likely talking to other firms
the place where the discussion starts to
change tenor a little bit is when one
firm says hey look you know this is
something we're pretty clear we want to
move forward with we've got some process
ahead of us but this is the direction
we're heading and we're interested in
syndicating risk so most venture deals
that get done today are done with at
least two investors in the initial round
and some of that is a risk reduction
strategy right if I can mitigate risk by
sharing it with others but the the
reality the real reason to do it is you
double the rolodex right so if you get
to very VCS from two different firms
you've doubled sort of the ability to
help with recruiting with partners with
other introductions etc and so most
firms have a strong bias towards
syndicating with one other firm and so
somewhere in that process there will be
a discussion around hey who else do you
think is kind of moving to the top of
your list because we'd like to start to
form a syndicate with them right and so
that's kind of the juggling act that you
have to figure out when do you start to
disclose some of those other names
yeah so it varies widely by by firm and
sort of how you define success obviously
colors that discussion for most venture
firms they find somewhere around a 30%
flat out mortality rate ie zero or asset
value of some sort they'll find another
sort of 30 to 40 percent that returns
call it 1 X 2 maybe 3 X their money
which 3 times your money and the public
markets today sounds fantastic
but you know for venture guys is not
considered a successful outcome
particularly it's not a bad outcome but
it's not a good one either and then the
remaining ones are the 10 X plus sort of
returns right and so your hope in
structuring a fund is that you will get
a few of sort of the outsized returns
you get a bunch that are sort of ok
returns and then you try to get you know
the fewest number possible that are just
flat-out zeros
good question so what does the cap table
look like effectively so the series a
cap tables actually don't deviate a
whole lot you know as much consternation
as there seems to be on both sides of
the table around what is valuation need
to look like the reality is the cap
table almost always looks the same it's
30% to the founders 20% option pool for
new employees 25% for venture investor
number-one 25% for venture investor
number two now you will see some skewing
of that in both directions depending
largely on the quality of the the
project right and this goes back to kind
of your earlier question around how far
do you have to get it to get venture
financing the further along you are the
more favorably that those numbers will
skew toward you and toward the rest of
the employee base the earlier you are
the more it will skew toward the the
favor of the investors but as a rough
order that's kind of the stereotypical
kind of series a structure yeah so
anywhere from three is six million yes
30% founders 20% management team 25%
venture investor 125 percent venture
investor
yes a venture firms will look at
anything their pros and cons to raising
angel financing the advantage obviously
is that you get capital into the company
sooner perhaps before it is mature
enough that it would attract an
institutional venture investor you also
will sometimes get some of the fame and
notoriety associated with that angel
investor particularly if they're going
to be actively involved in the company
somehow the the downside is that you
know generally they're paid pretty well
for that right so you know if the call
it thirty to sixty percent mortality
rate for venture guys sounds high you
know it is significantly higher for
angel investors and so they oftentimes
will extract greater value for that
early investment so that's the that's
the trade-off that you have to worry
about as a as an entrepreneur personal
introductions yeah
so we're generally pretty approachable
people so you I mean you you can you can
find us at all sorts of conferences and
events right remember our job at the end
of the day is to find great companies
and the dirty little secret to the
venture business is there much fewer you
know great companies and there are VCS
hunting for them and so while our job
sounds quite glamorous the reality is
it's not well so that may be one the
third party is by far the strongest but
those are to your point right are the
hardest to come by in some cases it's
serial entrepreneurs who have built
relationships in the past and so you can
obviously leverage those the other way
to do it is by proxy by finding advisers
that are interesting advisers to your
companies and odds are good that good
advisors in the valley are pretty well
connected to venture folks
I think the decks change over time but
it changes mostly because the maturity
of the business changes and you start to
fill out more of the detail around what
are you going to actually go do right so
a seed deck is probably pretty light on
content beyond sort of the vision of
here's what I want to go pull off
whereas a series a deck may have more
detail about what have you actually
built and what are some of the customer
conversations look like write a Series B
deck you now probably have some
customers and a product and a Series C
deck you now actually have a lot of
product and a lot of customers and you
know are starting to talk more about how
is the model scalable right so the the
maturity of the business dictates where
the focus of the content is but the same
eight section still apply one final
question
one thing that search that I'm going to
start up once they get pressed is that
they start getting lots of calls from
associates at VC firms asking for
information how realistically how should
those people be handled because from
what I've heard very few deals are
funded that come in to a venture capital
firm via that route yeah so that they're
they're different kind of categories of
that there are a series of firms that
are and I would put you know summit and
TA and others like that into the
category they're really kind of private
equity firms right and so they are
generally calling actively to find
generally cashflow profitable businesses
that they can then invest in that's
pretty different than sort of the the
seed that they you know heard about you
in a cocktail party and know that you
are you know going to the GSB event and
you know they want to come find you
there so the first set is kind of the
bifurcation between those two camps the
second piece to it right is is sort of
what is the timing that you actually
want to raise financing so don't let
venture interest preempt your process if
you don't think that you're ready yet
then you know don't don't go engage with
them so you know some of that you need
to control you know in terms of should
you actually respond to them or not
if you are ready to start talking to
venture folks and that's the strongest
introduction
you have to the firm then by all means
right that's better than sort of the the
blind email to them you know but on sort
of the the hierarchy of categories if if
you know your next-door neighbor and
best friend is a GP at that firm right
then that's probably the person you
ought to reach out to so it's I think
kind of timing and strength of
relationship would dictate whether you
should actually take it if you're in
that second category if you're in the
first category it's a profitable
business I don't think it actually
matters one iota how you get in the door
they're just simply interested in
whether it's a real company and whether
they can make money at it